Oh
you
alright this is Jeff Lima I'm here for
new media rockstars I'm with stian hasta
and he's the director of the new comic
web series STD odds Ferg is that correct
uh odd yes god you're okay no no s yeah
odd fyords some ok now the series shoots
on location in Norway correct yeah okay
so can you give us a just a quick
synopsis of STD odd fears for the NMR
readers who maybe don't know about you
well basically it's about this new york
city cop you know he's tired the
violence and you know the stressful new
york city life so he wants to get
transferred to someplace calm the NYPD
has recently started for a next inch
program with a norwegian state so he
gets offered to be sent to this small
small norwegian town called out cured
and he thinks this is going to be heaven
on earth but as it turns out in this
small town everyone's in criminal
everything else in the shootout and you
know it's not as peaceful as he thought
it would be nice it's a good good inter
there now how did the how does the idea
for the show come about well basically
i'm from a small town myself um and you
know we have all these like CSI shows
you know with New York and Miami and Las
Vegas and I've always been thinking how
funny it would be if you set one of
those shows to like a small town you
know instead of like a big big city but
then we quickly found out that you know
it's not not fun if nothing happens in
small town so we decided to have a small
town where basically everything happens
and it's way over the top and try to
make satire out of that now you guys
seem to have a pretty good-sized budget
for the show it seems w got a lot of
locations obviously I mean you're doing
the gunfire and stuff with
post-production but let me just step the
props and everything you've got going so
does the government help button anyway
or is it I mean all privately funded or
what uh well actually one third of it is
privately funded the rest is different
different like film funds and it's like
local a local phone fun and then a
national film fun because basically on
paper it's a television
pilot or a development project for a
television show and they have like
funding there are funding possibilities
in Norway to get that funded so we
applied for that and we got it but yeah
mostly the reason why it looks good is
because we will live in that city for
many many many years where we shots we
know all like where we can get our way
we can get a train you know a train
station that looks good and when we can
get all those small things that add up
and give it more production value now
you guys do you film in English to
maximize your global audience sir what
was the choice minor basically me and my
friend who's like co-writer and
co-director we have this YouTube channel
that we have piped a bit of a following
now I think about 200,000 subscribers
and they're from all over the world I
think about only like five percent of
them are Norwegian so when we got the
opportunity to do a real webseries we
wanted it to be in English so that we
could bring our fans you know along on
that ride and then we tried to come up
with a concept where it was logical that
it was in English even thought it was
set in Norway and so that's how it it
all turned out to be in English now how
did you guys find game coning who plays
the American detective in your series
how did you guys come across that guy uh
yeah Davis is so brilliant i go to a
columbia university here in new york and
i did a project for my directing actors
class and i had this this part and my
professor she said I have this guy for
you he's burly in his great comedic
timing he'll be perfect and so I used
tape there and that was one and a half
years ago and he's been in the back of
my head ever since and so now when we
got this opportunity to do this web
series I send him an email like do you
want to do it with a shoot fly over to
Norway and shoot it there and he's like
hey I'm down so basically we wrote the
whole series for him oh ok now yeah you
said you would go to Columbia how does
that is the guy from Norway end up going
to Columbia University's at it yeah well
it was a funny story I remember I was
sitting in my living room watching TV
when they are feeling like
as before done like sitting here doing
is being in this town I've done this for
such a long time I got to try something
different and so I thought about
applying for film school so I looked up
a bunch of different schools i found
that colombia fit my profile the most so
i applied i was lucky enough to get a
scholarship and so come here good night
now you're part of the the comedy duo I
guess pistol shrimps how does that come
about and it's kind of funny worse uh we
both went to the same undergrad back
home in Norway I was one year above him
and so we were standing at a party once
and I told him you know I always had I
always wanted so much to edit myself
into the Harry Potter films and he said
also do i and i actually have costumes i
was like no and so we just decided let's
do it and then i think we spent six
months making the first one and ever
since we just made more videos now you
guys do a lot of yes placing yourselves
into the action of you know mainstream
Hollywood films have you guys heard from
the the film studios or anything in
regards to that or the legality of it
well we had one video that got pulled uh
from from the internet because of that
but in more positive terms we had this
one this spring called Titanic super 3d
where we made a Titanic spoof and then
we got an email from the people who may
were making them behind the scenes and
stuff for the DVD release or the blu-ray
release they wanted to use segments of
that video for a documentary on the
blu-ray release so that was super fun no
that's really what pretty neat
distinction there yes shows now the
video that got pulled that was a
brokeback hogwarts it was called i think
okay maybe I'm too videos like okay
there's another one I know the brokeback
hard words got pulled by YouTube
basically because it was too like the
sex in it was too like we went far with
the the sex in it we had another one
that got polio was a pirates of the
caribbean spoof we're not sure if you
pulled it or if it was you know the
holders but basically we were told that
it was false advertising because he
could people could interpret it as a
real pirates film and it's not and so we
got like a warning and stuff so we
didn't put it back up now you guys have
a you have a pretty filthy good sense of
humor and which I gave completely of is
that diamond is that come from your
parents or where D word is that the
filthy humor come from I didn't know
it's hard to say you know I for me I'm
always had this like philosophy that
there are some things that are just like
they're funny to everyone you know like
poop jokes and fire trucks and sex jokes
they're just like they're in our
genetics to be funny and then if you can
but can combine that with telligent
humor or something that's more
intellectual then you will create the
best kind of humor that's why I'm like a
huge fan of south park in those kind of
shots to manage to combine combine that
stuff well yeah i'm not sure where he
comes from really now okay do you have
any comedic influences say American
comedic influences that you were kind of
excited oh yes south park i I'd watched
some persons since it started when I was
young you know and I gotta grew up with
the show as a show got more mature like
the first seasons it was all about poop
jokes apart roads that was what when I
like almost hit dirty so I grew up with
that show and I'd say that you know
smarter I grew up and and basically that
whole humor I find it very i just find
it very inspiring that makes a so called
a very childish humor and so-called
intelligent satire and and yeah and
parody thanks now why did you guys
choose the name pistol shrimps itself
well basically we needed something that
was logo friendly and catchy so we went
on Google and we searched for a funny
animal names and we made his long list
and then we went back and forth and we
could only agree on pistol shrimps
what's the one that we both like so then
became our thing panda yeah so basically
logo friendly was the most important
thing okay now there's a there's an
amateur sports team in London and also a
band that are both called pistol shrimps
have you guys heard from them or now we
haven't heard anything at all about that
um the only thing there's a video on
youtube of the species pistol shrimps on
how they shoot with the air bubbles and
we get sent that one all the time like I
have you seen this it's the real pistol
friends but uh know we haven't heard
about the ban or the sports team okay
now i love i love your web characters a
marking bill is it true that they are
having all of the sex all of the time
that is so true Michael de Lima that of
course that now are they based on anyone
in particular or are they completely
original one with it I think there are
based on ourselves as like our most
awkward sides as teenagers you know you
you try and think back think back about
like what was your most like it's
awkward sides and then you just try to
elevate those sides and just make them
into a character so yes sort of based on
ourselves we were kind of nerdy mallu
yet haha that's good that's good now is
a odd fjord is it full time for you now
or will there still be pistol shrimp
videos coming out there still will be
pistol from videos coming out hopefully
moving to treat more in January and we
have two or three more that we haven't
edited yet but for the next two months
is going to be odd pure um because it
comes out on BTW i know and then it
comes out on youtube one week later okay
and that's a that that's what the the
25th of october i think it comes out on
youtube yeah okay perfect now what guns
are pretty prevalent imaging your videos
you does norway have like a is it a
thriving gun culture or that's kind of
an American influence there it's very
much an American influence ah Thunder
culture is not big you know at all it's
for hunting and that's that's about it
um the gun laws are sort of strict at
least compared
to to America but yeah it's just all
influenced you know by American action
films and how like you know she'd first
ask later that kind of you know Stallone
Schwarzenegger stuff now what are some
other YouTube channels that you follow
personally Oh Lizzie I really love the
epic rap battles of history they're
absolutely brilliant they're so funny
one minute physics is just concealer and
so much and it's entertaining kassem g
is super funny what else I was a huge
fan of Baretta beretta but they don't
upload much anymore uh but yeah I think
that's but that's my favorite ones yet
okay now you've directed several short
films actually now are those available
online oh yeah they are um different
places I can send you some links few
nights one oh yeah ok knows those
interesting is the sum of them looks
interesting particularly what was it
short penis penis again yeah it's about
a support group for men who have small
penises it's like the setting of the
story so yeah that was some interesting
interesting film to make you know when
you're trying to cast a group of men you
have small penises on film yeah well I
know no I don't want to be in that
challenge I can imagine now I like will
epic horse from your recent horse video
be appearing in Oxford no unfortunately
not you know it ran away so you
something hold up you know it's too epic
well looks can thank you very much for
your time and we look forward to seeing
the show I got to see the pilot episode
I think it's hilarious and I'm excited
for more so we'll be in touch and thank
you very much for doing this thank you
all right have a good one you too
Oh